what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
details for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania specifically about Kang in a
major plot point for the movie coming
from the big man himself Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios in a recent
interview with Empire magazine he gave
us a lot of details about Kang the
Conqueror and specifically about his
situation inside of the quantum realm
and why he needs Ant-Man well if you
have watched the recent trailer for
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania and
by the way if you haven't you definitely
need to
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose but if you
have you actually saw a glimpse of why
exactly Kang needs Scott although it
wasn't very apparent just by watching
the trailer but now that we know now
that Kevin feige kind of told us why we
can clearly see what Ant-Man is doing
for Kang in the trailer so let's break
down this recent interview what Kevin
feige had to say and then go back to the
trailer and take a look at what Ant-Man
is doing for King and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Marvel videos now
as I mentioned this is an interview with
Kevin feige with Empire magazine and the
title of this article is Kang brings a
new kind of big bad to the MCU in
quantumania says Kevin feige and they
revealed an exclusive image here of King
the Conqueror of what seems to be him
sitting in his time chair now this could
simply be somewhat of a throne for King
the Conqueror inside of his big massive
City that he's built inside of the
quantum realm otherwise known in the
comics as chronopolis however we know
that his time chair is going to be how
he kind of travels through time and
Kevin feige basically tells us that in
this article so let's dive into the
article and see what it has to say it
starts off by saying in the Marvel
Cinematic universe's Infinity Saga it
took the combined might of the Avengers
plus Affiliated friends a time traveling
Quest several seismic superhero deaths
and a humble rat being in just the right
place at the right time to bring down
Thanos the Mad Titan he was at the time
of infinity war and in game by far the
biggest bad in the MCU but as Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania begins Phase 5
and kicks the Multiverse Saga up to the
next level a villain is coming whose
serious smarts Sinister aims and several
alternate selves will make defeating the
big purple guy look like a walk in the
park his name is Kang the Conqueror and
he wants nothing less than dominion over
absolutely everything across all
realities because he doesn't just exist
in a single Universe he's across every
branch of the multi diverse at War not
just with everyone else but every other
version of himself blimey now just right
here we have some amazing details about
King the Conqueror himself but here's
where Kevin feige comes in stating he is
the obvious choice as you're dealing
with the Multiverse Kang allowed us to
do a new kind of big bad he's a
different type of villain warring
amongst themselves as much as he's
warring with our heroes so if you've
been following the channel you know that
I have stressed this point a lot King
the Conqueror and the multiversal war
isn't between our heroes and Kang it's
really between Kang and the other
variants of himself of course our heroes
are eventually going to come in and try
to stop Kang in a lot of his variants
but remember in the beginning it was him
against himself all of his different
variants and it's the same here so we're
going to see multiple different variants
of Kang including an Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania there's not just going
to be one king but two but Kevin feige
goes on to give us even more details
Kevin feige continues to state Kang's a
very powerful person but when we meet
him he's in a position where he needs to
get that power back he has a ship and a
device that would allow him to go
anywhere and any win he wants if he can
get it online if only he had access to
genius scientists with Pim particles so
right there there you have it Kevin
feige has told us that is the main
reason that Kang needs Ant-Man because
of the Pim particles Kevin feige has
also confirmed that Kang is indeed stuck
inside of the quantum realm he has also
confirmed that there are indeed many
different variants of King and will be
running into them so the king that is in
charge of this giant City seems to be in
full power he seems to have total
control over his army over the city
we've seen it move a lot we've seen the
Rings move around it but why does Kang
need a Pim particle well what he really
needs is a Pim disc Kevin feige says
that when we meet Kang he's a very
powerful person but he needs to get that
power back now I believe he is
specifically talking about when he says
power a power source he means this in a
literal way not the power that comes by
being the king of the quantum realm but
physical power that is used to power his
time chair as I mentioned in the
beginning Kang and the comics uses his
time chair to travel through time that
is his time travel device however it
needs a power source to get it to be
able to work or as Kevin feige says get
back online he also kind of needs it
strong enough to be able to take a lot
with him like his giant army because
remember Kang has a lot of other kings
to go up against who all probably have
somewhat of an army themselves so this
power that King needs isn't just to
power a simple little time chair it's
basically to power the entire city and I
believe that we have seen this power I
believe that Ant-Man and multiple
different variants of Ant-Man are trying
to get this power this was shown in the
trailer and what does Ant-Man seem to be
doing well it looks like he is going to
shoot a pen M particle at this giant
source of power that would shrink it
down now this area that him and the
other Ant-Man are in from what we've
heard is called the quantum Nexus now
this name isn't specifically mentioned
in the comics however we do have the
Nexus of all realities and this does
actually fit with what king is and what
he's trying to do and the quantum realm
the Nexus of all realities is a place
that can take you wherever and whenever
you want into any reality and it can
even take you in between realities this
would explain why we are seeing a lot of
different Ant-Man in this scene all of
the different realities and all of the
different variants could be coming in so
if this power source is what powers the
quantum Nexus and possibly gives the
power to jump between realities this is
exactly what king wants but again it's
massive Kang couldn't simply harness
this power he couldn't simply grab this
device he needed the pin particle which
is what Kevin feige was saying he needs
a Pim disk to shrink it down so he can
actually harness it and actually use it
put it inside of devices so he could get
out of the quantum Realm so this is
King's plan his complete plan and why he
needs Scott why he needs Ant-Man but of
course it looks like Scott and everybody
else is going to find out what king is
actually up to in fact we know that
Janet Van Dyne knows King in fact
there's a rumor going around that Kang
and Janet really knew each other very
well before but Janna is part of the
reason that Kang is continuously stuck
inside of the quantum realm because she
sabotaged his ship this is why Janna is
so afraid of Kang and the two trailers
that we've seen it also makes this a
little personal for King not only has
King been stuck inside of the quantum
realm but his ship was sabotaged by
Janet Van Dyne so Kang is setting out
for Revenge as well and this is actually
how our main Avengers team will get
involved Kang is going to want revenge
on the universe that Ant-Man the WASP
stature or Stinger whichever they're
calling her in this movie Janet Hank the
universe that all of these characters
come from he wants revenge on not just
them but the entire universe and this is
where the Avengers come in we're not
exactly sure how many variants of K are
going to be in this movie but I know
that one of them who's going to be a
mang Kang is going to escape I'm
assuming Kang does not lose in this
movie I think it's kind of going to be
like Avengers Infinity War so I'm
assuming Kang gets out of the quantum
realm and this is where he starts to
become a problem for the Multiverse but
specifically our universe Kevin feige
stated he can go anywhere and any win as
long as his ship gets back online well
it does look like Scott is going to
indeed capture that power source shrink
it down and that is going to end up in
the hands of King and he's going to get
away and therefore the official Kang
Dynasty will have begun and I'm super
excited for this and everything that is
coming in Phase 5 and phase six and I
want to know how excited you are in the
comments down below so let us know don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign